hello everyone and welcome to the final
day of the oslo esports cup uh we are
going to cover a game uh from uh round
three of the match shakir madara vs
magnus carlsen and it's not going all
that great for magnus the first game
ended in the drawn uh the second game
ended by mamidyarov winning in 66 moves
it was a very hot for it in the game uh
but indian momodaro was able to win and
now magnus needs to bounce back so he
will try to do it with the black pieces
if he gets a draw here or uh
if he doesn't win or lose he will have a
chance again with the white pieces in
game four but if he loses this then that
is it mamadara wins the match it's a
very nice game uh let's check it out so
shakira has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 uh we have knight to f6 by
magnus c for g6 going for the king's
indian defense knight to c3 uh bishop to
g7 and now g3 preparing to think at the
light square bishop we have c5 by magnus
and now usually uh white will advance
the pawn to d5 or even play knight to f3
but here a mamidarov just plays d
captures in c5 and it's a very rare idea
uh one of the players that is uh fond of
this idea is uh vladislav
but
like i said it's it it's a very rare one
and you could go after the pawn with
knight to a6 but uh magnus goes for
queen to a5 he wants to pick up the pawn
this way both knight a6 and queen a5 uh
prevent the b4 from white but it's still
it's still a very tricky move to play
because then a knight e4 uh and well you
could go after the rook so this could be
one of the
uh one of the rare cases where b4 is not
actually recommended uh so bishop to g2
and now magnus picks up the pawn
queen captures on c5 we have bishop to
d2 and magnus castles rook to c1 d6 and
now pawn to b3 uh adding more defense to
the c4 pawn and now uh it's magnus to
move he plays knights to c6 we have
knight to f3 mommy are also ready to
castle now and here you could play
something like d5 it definitely makes
sense you want to open up the the
position rook to d8 makes sense the
queen is on d1 but magnus goes for queen
to h5 and it is actually only now as of
move 10 that we have a completely new
game so his idea is that um uh what well
how does he develop the light square
bishop well if bombay are of castles
he's just going to play bishop to h3 but
mommy are says not so fast let's play h3
first and now
what do you play here magnus plays h6
and now even g4 forcing the black queen
away from such an active square so
magnus goes all the way back queen to c5
now bishop p3 again attacks the queen we
have queen to a5 now uh with the
potential of some nasty discoveries if
the knight moves from f6 so mama yarov
adds another defender to the knight we
have queen d2 and now h5 magnus strikes
against the white's king side uh and uh
it's mamidarov
to counter this so he plays g5 of course
he doesn't uh want to open up the king's
side knights to d7 and now knights the
d5 here uh mamidarov is playing very
very cheeky as he's already leading in
the match he's offering a queen trade
and even though queen trade is the uh
probably the best uh
magnus can do here it's not all that uh
impressive if uh one wants to win the
game so magnus goes back queen to d8 uh
but now it's mamidarov who takes um at
the upper hand in the position we have
knights to d4 uh knight to c5 by magnus
and now knight captures on c6 we have b
captures and the knight to b4 now going
after the c6 spawn
and you should uh just play bishop to b7
but here comes a very very interesting
moment that uh well happens very often
in chess magnus plays queen to c7 and
mamedyarov just uh trusts magnus so here
we have bishop captures in c6 rook to b8
uh and now uh of course the threat is
just real captures knight here and then
we're gonna pick up the bishop and
mamiyarov just brings the bishop back
and here mamador kind of blindly trusts
magnus because instead of moving the
bishop back you could play knight to d5
and all of a sudden white controls all
of the squares and
what you're gonna do you're gonna move
the black queen back but then of course
you control all of all of these squares
and white's position is just excellent
of course if you capture the bishop the
knight captures an e7 check picks up the
queen so a very very interesting uh
moment in in a game
but it happens so when your opponent you
know uh
grabs a piece he hits the piece on the
board and uh you know don't don't just
uh trust your opponent always check if
there's something hidden so okay mommy
daryl goes back bash up to g2 now comes
a5 kicking away the knight knights the
d5 attacking the queen and here magnus
decides to go queen to a7 you could also
bring the queen back to keep an e7 pawn
from here uh but magnus decides to put
it here and this is already very very
dangerous
and mamadarov now only now castles you
could play knight f6 and it's a
super tricky idea the problem okay okay
if you capture them queen captures on d6
and that's it for black there's really
not much you can do here the problem is
after knight f6 check magnus could just
go back a king to h8 and now the game
still continues you will have to castle
and
pile up on this attack so mommy our
figures why not start with castles we
have castles now and bishop to e6 going
um oh well just developing and
connecting rooks now so even if uh
you try something with knight captures
here then you will be able to connect
the rooks and the knight will be nicely
defended so rook after d1 and now uh
bishop captures nd 5 by magnus c
captures and rook to b4 magnus uh
figures out how to activate the rooks uh
rook the c2 and mommy daryl will now
double up on the c file uh rook the c8
and rook d to c1 we have bishop to e5
and now we have rook to c4 uh so what
can magnus play here he plays queen to
b6 uh and now mommy are just trades rook
captures and b6 here again it's a very
interesting position where mamidarov
doesn't really have to rush anything
it's uh definitely him
who has the upper hand and he could just
play f4 and improve his position before
uh you know uh whenever he
he wishes he can just trade on b4 bishop
g7 then there should be three king g2 he
can improve his position as much as
possible before actually capturing on b4
but it's a rapid game of course he wants
magnus to burn his time as well rook
captures on b4 we have eight captures on
b4 uh and now we have rook to c4 so okay
the opponent b4
is very nicely placed now maybe black
can go after the a2 pawn but also it's a
target so here bishop to c3 now comes
queen to c2 and the queen to a5 now uh
we have bishop to e4 now putting
pressure on the g6 pawn so you can even
imagine a move like bishop captures and
g6 being played uh so king to h7 and now
okay mama darv says that's a very good
spot i'm gonna play bishop to f3 now the
threat is of course bishop captures an
h5 as the g6 pawn is uh pinned so king
back to g8 and here bishop e4 magnus
repeats mamadara repeats magnus repeats
and now majero doesn't want to repeat
with the white pieces because then
magnus will get a chance with the white
pieces to try and win and also his
position is just much much better so
king g2 and here magnus has to be very
very careful but his position is worse
regardless of what he plays uh he plays
rook to a8 and this uh allows mavidyarov
a very specific uh
set of moves that will force magnus into
a terrible terrible position so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find this only idea for mamadirov to
seize the initiative
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
wonderful idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is bishop
captures on c5 that's the good stuff of
course the queen can't capture so you
have to recapture with the pawn uh and
now pawn to d6 and this is now very very
uh serious serious trouble for magnus uh
the engine gives a4 as the absolute
strongest but this is a very positional
idea because black's position is already
so bad so of course you can't capture
because then the bishop hangs and you no
longer have to worry about your a2
weakness however for a practical rapid
game d6 is just as crushing the problem
is you can't allow this capture for
example if you trade queens here
captures captures we're just going to
play captures and now how do you stop e8
queen you can't play king to f8 and you
can't play rook day 8 so this would be
completely winning for mahmoud uh so
after d6 magnus captures on d6 and now
just bishop captures an a8 we have queen
captures an a8 with check king g1 and
now magnus plays d5 and uh probably
magnus already gave up on the game here
but if he was still uh mentally in the
game he would probably play bishop to d4
and then it's not so easy for uh for
white to
uh
prove that the rook is better than a
bishop in this position because the
the rook is just stuck here you're
threatening d5 uh it's a very very uh
tricky position to play but magnus
decided to play d5 and although this
does uh
advance the pawn further it does give
the white rook uh well just a lot more
space to work with so here rook captures
on c5 d4 now comes queen to d3 uh we
have a queen captures on a2 now comes
rook to c8 check king to h7 and here
mamadara played queen to f3 and he was
in this position in the position from
the thumbnail that magnus carlsen
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here he will get
checkmated or he will suffer severe
material loss
and that's just it there's no way out of
this so very nicely done by mommy
winning game two and three uh and thus
winning the match without allowing
magnus to try his chances with the white
pieces in game four
uh so really wonderful stuff for those
of you who always enjoy when i finish
the games there's really not all that
much for black to try here there aren't
any tricks or any anything you play
let's say queen a7 you guard the f7 pawn
as the white queen is attacking that
we're just going to play queen f6 and
that's it i mean uh no no i can just
start playing some silly moves but uh
other than that you really don't have a
much much other choice uh so yeah after
queen to f3 magnus resigns and a
brilliant brilliant victory for
mamidyarov who crushes magnus in the
final round of the oslo esports cup
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank fred
eckermann joseph verasuria robert arthur
alex cluster hoover and michael
mcconnell for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing uh to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens uh in the chess world we're
probably gonna cover a few more games
from this round so if you have any of
your own favorites do use hashtag
suggestion as usual
and we will check them out so yeah
once again hope you guys enjoyed it uh
see you soon